es ist die älteste handelskammer
deutschlands und wenn es um die
ursprünge geht werden sie hier ganz
feierlich das ist die gründungsurkunde
in der sich vor allen dingen die
seefahrenden kaufleute hamburgs
zusammengetan haben um ihre interessen
gegenüber der stadt zu vertreten und von
der stadt auch der erlaubt die erlaubnis
zu erhalten so eine vertretung zu
gründen
das war im jahr 1517 festgelegt wurde
damals auch wie sich ein guter kaufmann
verhalten soll
als person geht es darum dass er eben
geradlinig seine wirtschaftlichen ziele
verfolgt auf jeden fall aber das nicht
tut indem er eben seine geschäftspartner
auf die andere eine oder andere weise
ich sag jetzt mal ein bisschen direkt
übers ohr zu hauen versucht im
gewinnstreben sondern muss wissen dass
im geschäftsleben das geben und nehmen
und das stehen zum wort eben ein ganz
wichtiger grundsatz ist aber wird das in
den unternehmen heute noch gelebt in
hamburg gehören rund 1000 firmen zum
verein des ehrbaren kaufmanns wie die
lackfabrik markiert
michael grau ist der chef in dritter
generation
er versucht das alte leitbild im alltag
seines modernen familienbetriebs
umzusetzen
die 500 mitarbeiter stellen speziallacke
für den flugzeug und automobilbau her
kein leichtes geschäft denn die
konkurrenz wird weltweit immer größer
schnell können auch sicher geglaubte
aufträge wegbrechen
der unternehmer muss in neue anlagen
investieren und seine leute motivieren
kaufmann es gut ist ebbe und flut das
heißt mal läuft das geschäft sehr gut
war läuft es nicht so gut
und in beiden situationen haben sie eine
große verantwortung für ihre mitarbeiter
in einem fall das liegt vielleicht
stützend eingreifen wo das geschäft war
nicht so gut läuft
auf der anderen seite wenn sie sehen
dass das geschäft sehr gut läuft dass
sie den leuten auch dann an
entsprechende entlohnung oder vielleicht
mal einen zusätzlichen bonus oder
ähnliches geben können er bat zu sein
das bedeutet für den chef gerade in
schwierigen zeiten sich zu kümmern
er zahlt kinderzuschläge und über
tariflichen lohn für die belegschaft
vertrauen herstellen zu kunden und
lieferanten
auch das gehört für ihn dazu
im sechzehnten jahrhundert schlossen
diese kaufleute der hanse ihre geschäfte
noch per handschlag
heute gelten natürlich verträge bei
denen er hart aber immer fair verhandeln
will
bei uns geht es darum nachhaltig
geschäftsbeziehungen anzubahnen
verständnis füreinander zu gewinnen
vorteilhaftigkeit zu entwickeln
gemeinsam also win win situationen zu
schaffen und das ist vielleicht der
moderne handschlag
am letzten tag des jahres treffen sich
die ehrbaren kaufleute traditionell in
der handelskammer michael grau war schon
als kind zusammen mit seinem vater hier
gerade in zeiten von banken und
finanzkrise wollen diese unternehmer
zeigen dass man es besser machen kann
eine botschaft die auch michael grau in
seiner ersten abschlussrede vor dem
versammelten senat noch einmal deutlich
macht so ist es also gerade gut in
häufig orientierungslosen zeiten weisung
zu bekommen beraten zu werden und zum
handeln aufgerufen zu sein wenn es den
ähren bar ehrbaren kaufmann nicht jetzt
schon gebe jetzt wäre erfüllten und von
innen repräsentiert vielen dank